Speaker 1: We talked yesterday. We had two
relevant stories yesterday to what we're going to
talk about now, which is firings related to people
who are refusing to get vaccinated for their jobs
as required by their employers. Yesterday, we had
two stories sort of about this one story asked,
is it time to start firing unvaccinated employees
and mass, so to speak? That was one question we
talked about yesterday. Many of you wrote to me
and said, yeah, it is it once once you say those
are the rules, you've got to follow through.
Otherwise, these are empty threats. It's like
the parent who makes an empty threat to the kid
or, I don't know, whatever analogy you want.
The second question we asked yesterday in another
segment and many of you wrote in about this
one as well, is are some of the people saying
they're going to quit over a vaccine mandate,
lying or exaggerating or maybe even
misunderstanding their own willingness
to quit? And they're not really going to
quit. They're probably just going to go
and get vaccinated. And one of the examples we
had yesterday was Massachusetts state troopers,
where the union for the state troopers said we've
gotten dozens and dozens, you know, massive dumps
of resignation letters. The unions said that.
But state police, human resources said one one
trooper actually resigned. Now we'll see how it
all shakes out. We now have a couple of additional
data points. And it seems as though there are
people willing to quit, but more likely be fired
over not getting vaccinated. But yesterday's
assessment that it might only be half to one
percent, half of one to one percent of employees
at any given organization may well be right. Let's
look at a couple of data points. Washington Post
reporting North Carolina hospital system fires
about one hundred seventy five workers and one
of the largest ever mass terminations due to a
vaccine mandate. Timothy Bella writes. A North
Carolina based hospital system announced Monday
that roughly 175 unvaccinated employees were fired
for failing to comply with the organization's
mandatory covid vaccination policy. The latest in
a series of health care dismissals. We're going
to get to that. Novant Health said last week that
375 unvaccinated workers across 15 hospitals and
800 clinics had been suspended for not getting
immunized. They were given five days to comply.
Novant Health spokeswoman Megan Rivers' tweeted
Monday that almost 200 of the suspended workers
received their first dose by Friday. The hospital
confirmed that the rest of the suspended employees
who did not comply were fired, although the exact
number of those dismissed was not specified.
We stand by our decision to make the vaccine
mandatory as we have a responsibility to
protect our patients, visitors and team members,
regardless of where they are in our health system.
We couldn't be prouder of our team members who
made the choice to receive the covid-19 vaccine
and remain part of the team. Later, the article
says the mass termination of unvaccinated
hospital system employees is among the largest
of its kind to date. More than 150 health care
workers who didn't comply with the mandate. At
Houston Methodist, which was one of the first
to require the shots, were fired or resigned in
June after a federal judge upheld the policy. And
importantly. More than 99 percent of
the system's 35000 employees followed
the program. We have a few other data points here
as well. Beckers Hospital Review put out yesterday
a sort of summary of departures at 18 different
health systems. Now, departure could be firing
or resignation. It could be either. And it
includes St. Luke's University Health Network,
17000 employees, about one hundred and
fifty total refused to get vaccinated
and resigned. That is just under one percent.
Newark Delawares Christiana Care fired about
150, or the equivalent of under 90 full timers
for not complying in New York City, New York,
Presbyterian's 48000 team member system had fewer
than two hundred and fifty resignations firings.
That is about half of one percent right
along with our estimate from yesterday,
New Hyde Park, New York's Northwest Health had
about two dozen leaders not allowed to continue.
We don't know the total number there. So you can
go and look at the exact numbers here. But what
are we learning so far? First and foremost, it
does seem that when there is a disproportionate
amount of headlines about people resigning
or people saying, fire me, fire me, sirs,
that the real number of people willing to go and
whether it's a resignation or a firing, you know,
doesn't really make a difference. It seems that
it's about half of one percent to one percent.
That's number one. The second thing here is,
you know, when it comes to health care systems,
this is not just about the employer in a vacuum
saying you got to be vaccinated and otherwise
you're out with no real connection to reality.
This clearly also has to do with patients.
And what they should do is the nurses that don't
want to get vaccinated, the administrators that
don't want to impose vaccination. If there are
any the doctors that don't want to get vaccinated,
they should start their own clinic. They should
start their own hospital. If patients prefer to go
and be seen at a place where the employees, nurses
and doctors might be vaccinated or might not. But
it's not required if that's more appealing to
participants in the health care marketplace,
because that's what it is in the United States.
If people would rather go to the place where maybe
the employees and service providers, health
providers aren't vaccinated, then that would
be a business. Open a clinic and say, hey, if you
want freedom, come be seen here, come to our E.R.
We don't make the nurses get vaccinated.
We don't make the doctors get vaccinated.
If that's a popular idea in the marketplace of
ideas, then do it and it will be very profitable.
My prediction is most people who go to a health
care setting want to go somewhere where they know
the people providing care to them have been
vaccinated. But this is a great opportunity
to test it. What do you think would happen in that
situation? Let me know. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. The David Pakman Show
does depend on folks like you to support
the program. We have a membership program at
Join Pakman Dotcom. You get a commercial free
audio and video stream of the show every day.
We do an extra members only bonus show every
single day for our members. And you can use
the coupon code better 21 to sign up today.